hallo hallo mein name ist mir und heute
möchte ich dir meine vorsätze für das
neue jahr verraten
mein name ist mir und heute möchte ich
dir meine vorsätze für das neue jahr
verraten
dieses jahr war voller überraschungen
wir mussten uns einer pandemie stellen
und lernen mit ihr zu leben dieses jahr
war voller überraschungen
wir mussten uns einer pandemie stellen
und lernen mit ihr zu leben
wir haben gelernt das was wir heute
haben mehr zu schätzen und unsere
familien und unsere freiheit mehr zu
lieben
wir haben gelernt das was wir heute
haben mehr zu schätzen und unsere
familien und unsere freiheit mehr zu
lieben
heute möchte ich mit dir meine vorsätze
für das kommende jahr teilen und der
einige tipps für die vorbereitung auf
das nächste jahr geben
heute möchte ich mit dir meine vorsätze
für das kommende jahr teilen und der
einige tipps für die vorbereitung auf
das nächste jahr geben
dieses jahr habe ich von zu hause
gearbeitet
mein ziel für das nächste jahr ist mich
zu hause besser einzurichten damit ich
konzentrierter und bequemer arbeiten
kann
mein ziel für das nächste jahr ist mich
zu hause besser einzurichten damit ich
konzentrierter und bequemer arbeiten
kann
ich habe dieses jahr fünf kilo
zugenommen
nächstes jahr möchte ich mehr sport
machen um abzunehmen
ich habe 2020 eine menge geld ausgegeben
ab 2021 möchte ich anfangen zu sparen
ich hatte dieses jahr kein soziales
leben
im jahr 2021 würde ich gerne neue
bekanntschaften machen
ich war das ganze jahr 2020 single
mein ziel für das nächste jahr ist einen
partner zu finden
ich bin dieses jahr noch nicht gereist
bin dieses jahr noch nicht gereist
im nächsten jahr würde ich gerne mehr
reisen und neue orte entdecken
ich habe mein haus dieses jahr nicht
renoviert
2021 werde ich mein haus streichen und
dekorieren
spezial frage
was ist richtig
dieses jahr hatte ich kaum zeit für
sport im 2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport
treiben
b
um 2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport
treiben
2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport treiben
spezial frage
das ist richtig
dieses jahr hatte ich kaum zeit für
sport im 2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport
treiben
b
um 2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport
treiben
2021 möchte ich gern mehr sport treiben
[Musik]
dieses jahr hatte ich keine zeit zum
lernen
im nächsten jahr würde ich gerne eine
neue sprache lernen
das rauchen schadet meiner gesundheit
nächstes jahr werde ich versuchen mit
dem rauchen aufzuhören
ich habe mich dieses jahr nicht sehr
gesund ernährt
2021 werde ich mich gesund ernähren und
eine diät machen
ich habe 2020 viel zeit mit meiner
familie verbracht
im neuen jahr würde ich das gerne wieder
tun
im jahr 2020 habe ich viel alkohol
getrunken
im jahr 2021 werde ich versuchen den
alkoholkonsum zu reduzieren
ich habe 2020 keinen sport gemacht
2021 möchte ich anfangen sport zu machen
ich habe dieses jahr keine bücher
gelesen
bis ende 2021 werde ich mir vornehmen
mindestens fünf bücher zu lesen
meine mutter hat 2020 oft für mich
gekocht
ab 2021 werde ich lernen wie man kocht
dieses jahr habe ich nur in meiner firma
gearbeitet
nächstes jahr würde ich gerne in ein
geschäft investieren um ein zusätzliches
einkommen zu generieren
nächstes jahr würde ich gerne in ein
geschäft investieren um ein zusätzliches
einkommen zu generieren
dieses jahr war ich sehr unorganisiert
im jahr 2021 werde ich mir vornehmen
organisierter zu sein
2020 habe ich viel zeit mit meinem handy
verbracht 2020 habe ich viel zeit mit
meinem handy verbracht 2021 werde ich
mir vornehmen pausen vom handy und
sozialen netzwerken zu machen
2021 werde ich mir vornehmen
pausen vom handy und sozialen netzwerken
zu machen
dieses jahr habe ich mir eine gitarre
gekauft
im jahr 2021 werde ich lernen sehr gut
gitarre zu spielen
ich weiß noch nicht wie man auto fährt
ich möchte deshalb im jahr 2021 ein
neues auto kaufen und lernen wie man es
fährt ich möchte deshalb im jahr 2021
ein neues auto kaufen und lernen wie man
es fährt ich hatte dieses jahr kein
haustier
ich hatte dieses jahr kein haustier
nächstes jahr werde ich mir ein haustier
anschaffen
ich möchte beruflich weiterkommen
also werde ich nächstes jahr studieren
ich habe die letzten jahre bei meinen
eltern gelebt ich habe die letzten jahre
bei meinen eltern gelebt
nächstes jahr möchte ich unabhängiger
werden und alleine leben nächstes jahr
möchte ich unabhängiger werden und
alleine leben dieses jahr habe ich nicht
viel zeit mit meinen freunden verbracht
dieses jahr habe ich nicht viel zeit mit
meinen freunden verbracht nächstes jahr
würde ich gerne mehr zeit mit ihnen
verbringen
nächstes jahr würde ich gerne mehr zeit
mit ihnen verbringen
ich habe in diesem jahr 2020 nicht viel
wasser getrunken
mein ziel für 2021 ist mindestens acht
gläser wasser pro tag zu trinken um in
form zu kommen
mein ziel für 2021 ist mindestens acht
gläser wasser pro tag zu trinken um in
form zu kommen
spezial frage was ist richtig im neuen
jahr würde ich gerne mehr sport treiben
damit gesünder zu werden um mich
gesünder zu werden
c damit ich gesünder werde
[Musik]
ich habe dieses jahr einige bank kredite
aufgenommen
nächstes jahr werde ich alle meine
schulden abbezahlen
ich habe
soft red gekauft
im jahr 2021 werde ich surfen lernen
ich bin dieses jahr ziemlich lange auf
geblieben weil ich serien und filme
geschaut habe
ich bin dieses jahr ziemlich lange auf
geblieben weil ich serien und filme
geschaut habe
mein vorsatz für das nächste jahr ist
früher ins bett zu gehen
meine tipps für das neue jahr sind setzt
seine prioritäten für das nächste jahr
schreib und planen die schritte die duh
unternehmen muss um im nächsten jahr
dorthin zu gelangen
schreib und plan die schritte die die
unternehmen muss um im nächsten jahr
dort hinzugelangen plant einen zeitplan
und deine routinen mit einem fokus auf
die ziele für dieses jahr 2021 hast
plant einen zeitplan und deine routinen
mit einem fokus auf die ziele wie du für
dieses jahr 2021 hast
machen der das jahr 2021 zum besten jahr
unseres lebens und denkt daran die
feiertage mit denen zu genießen die du
am meisten liebst machen wir das jahr
2021 zum besten jahr unseres lebens und
denkt daran die feiertage mit denen zu
genießen die du am meisten liebt nun
freunde
ich freue mich meine neujahrsvorsätze
mit euch geteilt zu haben
nun freunde ich freue mich meine
neujahrsvorsätze mit euch geteilt zu
haben
was sind deine vorsätze für das neue
jahr
jahr schreibt sie in den kommentaren
schreibt sie in den kommentaren
denkt daran sehr diszipliniert zu sein
vermitteln sie erfüllen kann denkt daran
sehr diszipliniert zu sein damit du sie
erfüllen kann
hallo deutsch schule wünscht dir ein
gutes neues jahr
bis zum nächsten mal wir sehen uns
später